every now and then someone of Indian
origin wins a position of power around
the world it happened earlier this year
when Ajay Banger became head of the
World Bank it happened last year when
Rishi sunak became prime minister in
Britain it got me wondering is a
diaspora really that powerful or are
these just one-off examples
[Music]
and I'm International correspondent at
The Economist
there are 280 million migrants around
the world about 18 million of them come
from India that makes it the world's
largest diaspora but it's not just the
size of the Indian diaspora that makes
it so powerful it's the massive span of
countries that they have moved to
there's lots of Indians living in the
Middle East in countries like Saudi
Arabia and the UAE working in
construction and Hospitality reporting
in Kenya a few years ago I was really
struck by the number of business people
I met who were of Indian origin some of
these people were third fourth
generation Indians but they still
visited India they still seem to have a
little Community there in Nairobi and
they all seem to still hold on to their
Indian roots and perhaps most
importantly for the power of the Indian
diaspora there's lots of Indians Living
in America Australia throughout Europe
foreign
working with some academics at the Johns
Hopkins University in Washington DC to
try to quantify the power of the
diaspora we looked at S P 500 companies
and the chief Executives there we found
that currently there are probably 25
people of Indian origin leading S P 500
companies that's up from just 11 a
decade ago similarly we looked at the
legislatures in Britain the US in
Australia and Singapore and there too
there were very large number of people
on Indian origin it's not surprising
that the Indian diaspora is so powerful
India has all the ingredients to be a
top exporter of talent it's got a large
population an English-speaking Elite and
really good higher education for the
select few who get in
a smart and successful Indian diaspora
is an important tie between Western
countries and India at a time when the
post-war liberal order is being tested
when China and Russia are really facing
up to the West is incredibly important
for Western countries to keep up this
relationship with India every time Prime
Minister Modi makes a trip somewhere
overseas you really see that so last
month in Australia for example I
remember watching Prime Minister Modi
speaking in front of thousands and
thousands of Indian Australians
up on stage with him was his Australian
counterpart Anthony Albanese I said to
my friend the prime minister
to beat the welcome the Prime Minister
Modi has got
the Prime Minister from Australia was
not going to miss his moment to speak in
front of the Indian Community there
prime minister
whatever's been happening recently with
some democratic backsliding this is a
large Democratic country that is growing
fast and doing well
Mr Modi heads to America soon there'll
probably be another big Jamboree with
the diaspora there it will be further
proof that Mr Modi needs that diaspora
and Western leaders need them too
thanks for watching if you'd like to
read more of our coverage of Foreign
Affairs please click the link and don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]